[Musik]
endlich wieder wahlpartys endlich ein
stück normalität nur bei der cdu war die
stimmung jetzt nicht so
das war tatsächlich eine katastrophe für
die leute die hier sind als die bilder
die die zahlen eben taten wer hat
überhaupt niemand die jubeln außerdem
kollegen von der heute show
ja mehr als annina shit
sie sind heute zur cdu wahlparty
gegangen war das der einzige fehler den
sie heute gemacht haben es war von ganz
beschissene woche gewesen und deshalb
wie gesagt heute geht es noch
beschissener weiter so ist es dann halt
wir haben jetzt die chance das ganze
einfach auch friedrich merz zu schieben
es wird gesendet
mehr als bei der cdu am heutigen abend
wollen sie vielleicht zur aufmunterung
paar saarland wird zum beispiel der
machtwechsel geht von cdu spd oder wie
man im saarland sagt es bleibt in der
familie
wir können jetzt noch mal in die kamera
sagen wie sehr sich ak vermissten in
diesem moment ich vermisse ak
unwahrscheinlich denke noch an unser
gemeinsames elfi annegret
ja so intim sollte es jetzt gar nicht
werden ja ich glaube ich die maschen ich
komme gerade von der spd warum gehen sie
denn jetzt schon ja meint akl wartet zu
hause auf mich von den dackel doch mal
dackel sein lassen
das ist also menschenliebe ist das eine
und dann kommt die tierliebe und von
daher ist das bei mir ganz ausgewogen
bettelt im saarland aber auch darum dass
man diese witze macht ne ne ist der
dackel ihr lebensgefährte seien sie
ehrlich also irgendwo schon ja du wirst
niemals kennenlernen dann würden sie ihm
nicht widerstehen können glauben sie mir
das ne dienst noch mit zu mir nach hause
ihr habt doch gute laune heute da nicht
guck dich um mein freund setzt hier aus
dass wegen der schlecht glaubt
es gibt zwei personen denen man jetzt in
der spd besonders danken muss in diesem
wahlkampf oder natürlich anke auf alle
fälle und ich würde unsere
bildungsministerin auch noch sehr dornig
meinte jetzt oskar lafontaine und tobias
hans
naja gut okay
wir wollen jetzt nicht schadenfroh sein
dass es nicht unser stil sei ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt soll nicht noch schwankt der
kinder später wieder lösche profilen
jahren die anke bei mir im keller
der pastor sterling hat marvin und die
angehört sind betrieb genommen im
installiert der zusammen
das war schon der richtige weg zum
auftrieb sie haben recht das werden wir
später wieder löschen
über 40 prozent für die spd sie wissen
schon dass sie uns bei der heute show
damit ein ganzes negativ zerstören
hier kann ich mich natürlich nur in
aller form bei den zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer der heute-show entschuldigen
aber
wir werden liefern in der regierung ich
hoffe nicht allzu viel material liefern
nicht ehrlich heute so nicht ich habe
sie das so verstanden schöne party hier
bei der spd ob ich glaub ich wechsele
nochmal den laden und trinken absacker
so und in einem klassischen heute-show
bericht vom wahlabend dürfen natürlich
auch die fdp witze nicht fehlen nicht
drin im parlament haben die liberalen
halt mehr zeit zum porsche fahren und
jetzt ab auf die tanzfläche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die haben gesagt die soll meinen
lieblings witz erzählt es mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in einer bar sagt der
barkeeper
sony endlich den fakten heute schon
kanal also geht doch